foreign
Schultz I'm new here on Journey to the
micro Cosmos and I've been put up to a
very questionable task for my first
episode while the other new hosts get to
talk about beautiful microbes like
veggietoa I'm here to talk to you about
butts a whole compilation of them and I
know why I've been asked to do this I'm
a producer for scishow and one of the
hosts of the lightly competitive science
game show podcast scishow tangents and
each of our episodes ends with a butt
fact where one of our panelists recites
a fact about butts or poop or something
vaguely butt related we've also been
known to argue about important
existential questions that can shake you
to your very core like is butt legs but
as someone who's on team but his legs I
have to admit that microbes make a
compelling argument for the opposition
because so many of them don't have legs
but still have a butt like in this first
video about the flowery looking animal
called bryozoa when you first see them
you'll probably be like wait where's the
butt but stick around and you'll find
out why that's actually a very important
question for scientists studying the
briozoa
if I were to ask you to just do a little
sketch of what you think of when you
hear the phrase Moss animals you might
imagine something like this tardigrade a
waddling slightly Fantastical creature
that we did in fact find living within
the minuscule Greenery of moss but
depending on who you are and what you
know maybe you draw something completely
different maybe you draw something more
like this
these don't really look much like an
animal at all do they at first glance
they seem a bit more like plants with a
stalk connecting a series of flowers
with thin elegant petals but no that is
indeed an animal one that has the
dubious honor of being defined largely
by its anus
before we get there though let's start
with just explaining what these animals
actually are these organisms are members
of the phylum bryozoa a name that
translates in Greek to Moss animals but
bryozoa aren't actually animals that
live in Moss they get their name because
of what they look like when all of the
elegant individuals you see here
congregate into colonies but look you
know Mossy
that giant gelatinous mass seems to Bear
little resemblance to the tiny Winsome
creatures that make it up but ryozoa are
notable in the animal kingdom because of
just how Colonial the phyla is around
the world in waters salty and not are
colonies of different shapes and sizes
made up of individuals like these these
colonies can get their start in
different ways some might be the result
of sexual reproduction sperm and egg
that could have met in the waters away
from their makers or in other cases one
Colony may have captured sperm released
by another using it to fertilize its own
eggs which stay brooding until a larva
emerges ready to set out and develop its
own colony
but bryozoa have another asexual option
for reproduction instead of fertilizing
an egg a colony can amass a bunch of
cells into a structure like this one
called a stata blast
these stata blasts can be so prevalent
in our samples that James our master of
microscopes has to scoop them out to
keep them from being the main focus of
our videos they are thick and durable
able to lay dormant and protect their
contents from cold temperatures and dry
weather but when the conditions become
right again they grow into a new
individual that will form the basis of a
new colony
to do that the individual bryozoa called
a zooid navigates the waters as a larva
eventually attaching itself to some kind
of solid surface perhaps a piece of rock
or some kind of shelf maybe even some
seaweed and from there it will begin to
divide budding off but keeping its
descendants close and connected as they
increase in number
the arrangement of the zooids dictates
the shape of their colony as does the
material they secrete to support the
colony overall some excrete a gelatinous
material that turns them into those
masses of jelly we saw earlier others
rely on kindness materials that give
them more rigidity and as they spread
over their surface and even grow up into
the water around them bryozoa colonies
take on many spectacular shapes
even though bryozoa are different from
Coral they definitely look similar and
like Coral bryozoa colonies don't move
instead they remain attached to their
service but while they may not be able
to move through the world around them to
gather resources bryozoa are able to
make the most of their surroundings with
individual zooids taking on special
functions that allow the group to
accomplish more than the individuals
some focus on making eggs while others
form small beaks that allow them to snap
at predators and these zooids are all
dependent on another group of zooids
that gather food and share the nutrients
with everyone else
to get that food the feeding zoids rely
on the loaf of four the Ring of
tentacles crowning every zoid's bodies
that looks a bit like a bunch of thin
petals or a very elegant duster those
tentacles are covered in cilia which
circulate the waters around the briozoa
stirring currents like the ones you see
here so that it can sweep bits of food
like Plankton toward the animal's mouth
and from certain angles you can see how
the lovophore and the rest of the zoids
organs tuck into a sort of casing which
is a structure called the cysted and
while the briozoa has various other
parts that we could talk about what
we're really here for is the anus which
is a much bigger deal than you might
expect from an animal with such a simple
digestive system
there is a mouth an esophagus and then a
U-shaped gut that leads to the anus
and the issue has really rooted in the
existential crisis at the heart of
microorganisms how are things related to
each other and what does that mean for
the names that we give to things
organisms like these were originally
given the name polyzoa in 1830 but that
was changed a year later to bryozoa by
the German naturalist Christian
Ehrenberg but as more organisms were
added to the group the people watching
them and describing them realized that
they were actually lumping together two
very similar groups of organisms that
actually had some key differences
between them and one of those key
differences was where the organism's
anus was located one group had their
anus situated just outside of their loaf
of four that tentacle Crown we were
watching gather food earlier and one had
their anus situated just inside their
loaf of four so to differentiate between
these two groups scientists gave them
very appropriate names one group was
called ectoprocta which translates in
ancient Greek to outside anus and the
other were called the ento procta which
means inside anus because you can Define
anything by its but as long as you turn
to ancient languages in general bryozoa
typically refers to the ectoprox though
for many reasons I can't possibly
imagine why bryozoa seems to be the
preferred name but the history and
relationship between the ectoprocs and
endoprox remains an ongoing mystery that
scientists continue to explore
they are certainly not the only animal
out there to be wrapped up in a
phylogenetic mystery but isn't it great
to know especially for such a strange
animal like this that the mystery is
built on butts
[Music]
imagine if your name translated to
inside anus or outside anus I guess it
sounds better in ancient Greek but still
sometimes scientists make a lot of
strange choices like the subject of our
next video Anthony Von lavenhoek the
original master of microscopes lavenhook
looked for microbes in all sorts of
interesting places but given the subject
of our video today I think you can
figure out one of the more unique
sources of microbial Delights that
lavenhook found
in the year 1675
I discovered very small living creatures
in rainwater which had stood but few
days in a new earthen pot glazed blue
Within
those are the famous words that Anthony
vanlevin hook used to describe microbes
though he didn't use the word microbe he
called them anamolecules and the letter
itself is not exactly the one he wrote
leaving Hook's version was written of
course in Dutch and then sent off to
Henry Oldenburg the secretary of the
Royal Society in London who founded the
publication philosophical transactions
Oldenburg translated lavenhook's work
into English and published it in 1677
the rest as they say
is microbiology
[Music]
in 1932 the scientist Clifford dobel
published a biography of lavenhook
called Anthony van levinhawk and his
little animals devel introduced his
subject with some self-consciousness for
taking on the story of someone who if
you've been interested in microscopy you
have almost certainly heard of and he
wrote dear reader I know full well that
you and everyone else must have met Mr
van Leven hook many a time before but
please let me reintroduce him to you for
he is a man worth knowing more
intimately though he was born exactly
300 years ago he is still very much
alive and would be glad to make you a
better acquaintance provided only that
you are quote a true lover of learning
as of course you are
the fascination with lavenhook's work
for dobel and so many of us lies in the
scope of lavenhook's curiosity and the
writing that documented many of his
journeys into the microcosmos
[Music]
born in the Netherlands in 1632
lavenhoek was a draper by trade meaning
that he sold cloth he took up microscopy
as a hobby learning to grind lenses and
turn them into a tool to see in two Tiny
Worlds the simple microscopes he built
were better than many of those of his
contemporaries producing images that
were both more magnified and more clear
though of course compared with what the
average high school biology class has
today they were very bad at both of
those things
the creatures lavenhoek described in his
1677 publication were not his first
description of tiny animals in water
though in 1674 he wrote of green streaks
spirally wound a description that later
observers have taken to refer to the
filamentous green algae spirogyra he
also wrote of little creatures he'd
found that were as he described them a
thousand times smaller than the smallest
ones I have ever yet seen upon the Rind
of cheese those little cheese rind
creatures he was describing were likely
mites
[Music]
work it's kind of like following an old
treasure map his words lay out Pathways
and clues that help us navigate through
a drop of 17th century water and if you
follow that map at the end you find a
wealth of information the knowledge of
microbes and their identities that was
still unknown in his time but that in
the centuries since has been accumulated
[Music]
for dobel lavenhoek's 20th century
scientist biographer this treasure hunt
was a long one born out of his own
enchantment with these original
discoveries and a desire to better
understand them he learned Dutch only
Divine that the 17th century Dutch of
labanok's letters was impenetrable to
him and with World War One raging around
him he had to set aside his attempts to
translate lavenhook's work for some time
but eventually through what seems to be
largely a lot of determination dobel was
able to work his way through lavenhoek's
letters and that Labor of Love Led
naturally to translating things like
lavenhoek's descriptions of his own poop
Purdue Bell lavenhook wrote The
Following
I have usually of a morning a
well-formed stool but hitherto I have
had sometimes a looseness of the bowels
my excrement being so thin I was at
diverse times constrained to examine it
but lavenhoek wasn't documenting his
tool just for the sake of it in that
sample he saw an opportunity to observe
the animals within I have at times seen
very prettily moving animolecules their
bodies were somewhat longer than Broad
and their belly which was flattened
provided with several feet with which
they made such a movement through the
clear medium and the globules that we
might fancy we saw apisabed running up
against a wall that description sounds
promising but dobel had a problem
lavenhook had compared his microbes to
episabet and like you and I dobel had no
idea what episo bed was even the
original English translation he'd read
Shrugged it off as a Dutch term with no
obvious English equivalent dobel had
defined a 17th century Dutch English
dictionary to figure out that a Pisa bed
is a wood Laos and with that reference
point dobel had enough to diagnose
slavenhook very belatedly of course with
Giardia the product of a flagellate
known as giardia intestinalis
[Music]
at the time leaving Hook was identifying
the microbial residence of his stool he
almost certainly didn't know their role
in his poor digestion nor did he of
course have any name for them or any of
the other microbes that we now know he
saw and yet we can identify rotifers
from his characterization of their
wheeled heads and forticella from his
description of their belled bodies the
irony of our centuries later fascination
with reconstructing and replicating
lavenhook's work is that his
contemporaries had a much harder time of
it lavenhoek didn't help his cause much
refusing to provide extensive details of
his methods and even keeping his
microscope building techniques to
himself he did however provide eight
signed testimonies from various men
including a minister to verify that he
had made these observations
of course signed testimony is one thing
reproducibility is another
several of lavenhoek's contemporaries
tried and failed to replicate his
observations until finally Robert Hook
the famed microscopist and writer
illustrator of micrographia was able to
see the tiny animolecules lavenhoek had
seen hook however was willing to outline
his specific methods and demonstrate
them validating the observations
lavenhook had made and providing others
with the means to make their own
microbial Ventures and like dobel
centuries later Hook was reportedly so
taken with leaving Hook's work that he
learned Dutch to read his letters the
legacy of lavenhook is in the microbes
he uncovered but of course it was more
than that it was also the Curiosity that
he passed on and the acts of
interpretation that they inspired both
literally with all of these scientists
taking up Dutch to just learn from his
letters and then scientifically as we
decipher what microbes he must have seen
and so it seems fitting to close with
how lavenhook viewed his own little
animal kills he said
among all the Marvels that I have
discovered in nature these are the most
marvelous of all
[Music]
I know I'm supposed to think it's gross
that lavenhook dug into his own poop for
microbes but as weird as it is I also
respect the dedication to his craft but
now I want to know how many other noted
scientists have documented and studied
their poop so thoroughly that future
historians can diagnose them with an
intestine parasite is it just lavenhook
making him a true legend well I probably
spent too much time already thinking
about leaving Hook's butt which brings
me to my next question what's the big
deal about butts anyway why do we really
need them luckily there's an animal that
can teach us that flat worms a worm so
simple that it doesn't have an anus
[Music]
there are no ghosts in the micro Cosmos
there is no Halloween in the micro
Cosmos but if there were this flatworm
would fit in quite nicely with its
spectral appearance it might be
navigating its way through a field of
other organisms but it looks like it had
three minutes to prepare for a costume
party and decided to go with the classic
old bed sheet with eye holes ghost
costume and maybe comparing this
flatworm or even worms in general to a
ghost
is kind of Apt ghosts straddle Two
Worlds and so do worms though in their
case instead of Bridging the realm of
the living and dead worms managed to
stretch between the micro and the macro
this creature you're watching now would
probably be difficult to see without a
microscope but on the other end there
are worms that are meters too long to
observe with a microscope and Akin to
ghosts worms might seem like a sort of
reduced form of life after all
for a lot of us worms are the weekly
tubes that we dug up from playgrounds
and of all of the worms flatworms
or perhaps the most simple of all but
even digging into what it means to be
the simplest worm makes the whole notion
of Simplicity seem ludicrous
so let's start with the broader question
what are worms other than Wiggly
self-mating tubes
while we generally use the word worm to
describe many different unrelated
invertebrate tubular animals that belong
to a number of different phyla there are
three main phylum that people focus on
the first are our flatworm buddies here
who are known more formally as the
platyhelmenthes then there is the phylum
nematoda known less formally as round
worms we've come across nematodes many
times in our journey through the micro
Cosmos which makes sense given that they
are one of the most abundant animals on
this planet
and last are the annelida phylum of our
playground friend the earthworm while
earthworms are a bit beyond the scope of
the micro if you will we've also got
this little stylaria locustres at the
tip of its head is the proboscis an
antenna-like structure that the worm
uses for feeding and as we scan past the
head you can see that the length of this
dilarious body is segmented
of the three phyla we've mentioned
annelids are the most complex they have
a closed circulatory system with tubes
that transport nutrients and oxygen
throughout their body as well as a
complete digestive system that has both
a mouth to take in food and an anus to
get rid of waste if we think of worms in
general as a gut enclosed within a body
wall then that gut is a tube and the
body is a tube and you can imagine that
worms are a tube inside a tube and what
separates these different groups is the
space that separates one of those tubes
from the other complex systems inside
annelids are due to what's called a
sealum a tissue-lined cavity that sits
between the tube of the digestive tract
and the tube of the body wall
importantly this cavity is filled with
fluid which facilitates the development
of organs along with the transport of
nutrients around the body the
development of the first celum was a
very big deal because sealums don't just
allow annelids to have complex systems
they connect the seemingly simple
organisms we're talking about here to
more complex animals like us because
annelids and humans are both what is
known as selamates or ucelamates we are
animals that have sealums so thank you
to the ancestor that we share with
earthworms who developed the first celam
who allowed more complex organisms like
you to exist nematodes on the other hand
are what are called
pseudosealamates they still have a
seleum-like fluid-filled cavity but the
cavity isn't lined with tissue like you
find in true silums other microscopic
pseudosilamates include gastrotricks and
rotifers the
pseudosilum is a slight but significant
difference in nematodes when compared to
annelids corresponding to a slightly
less complex body plan though nematodes
still do have a complete digestive
system
the flatworms are the simplest of all
starting with the celum flatworms don't
actually have one they are considered
acylamates that area between the gut and
body wall where annelids and nematodes
have a cavity full of fluid is instead
full of tissue this has a few
consequences for the flatworm but one of
the biggest ones is that the area can't
support the development of specialized
systems that you see in other animals
the lack of silum imposes limits on the
flatworms body and lifestyle reducing
both its complexity and size but that
does not mean the flatworm lives a
simple life
oh
foreign
[Music]
groups flatworms are the most like a
tube within another tube except that
their outer tube is much less
cylindrical the flat and flatworm is
actually an adaptation without a
circulatory system or respiratory system
the worm relies on diffusion across its
outer membrane to supply cells with
oxygen being flatter gets the cells
closer to the outside and better
positioned for diffusion and without the
ability to build a complete digestive
system like those found in nematodes and
annelids flatworms have to adjust to
life without that most underappreciated
body part of all the anus they take in
food through one opening digest it in
their gut and then spew the waste back
out from that same opening so unlike
other organ who have separate entrances
and exits for their food the flatworm
must wait to finish digesting before it
can eat again but this is not the only
way flatworms can get rid of waste their
body is lined with a special type of
cell called a flame cell that also gets
waste out of the worm while it may not
have the Elegance of an interconnected
set of organs this system is its own
form of complexity basically every flame
cell is one single-celled kidney
allowing the worm to just lose waste
from its skin and this is just
scratching the surface of the biological
intricacy flatworms are capable of like
many of their more involved worm
counterparts flatworms can reproduce
both asexually and sexually and when
reproducing sexually they can mate with
another flatworm or even with themselves
both making and fertilizing their own
eggs
there's also those flatworm species that
can regenerate a trick that our more
developed bodies are alas not capable of
even the many weird ways they move make
the word wiggle feel reductive
foreign
[Music]
of Simplicity across nature is built on
comparisons compared to us on earthworm
may seem simple but that earthworm next
to a flatworm and suddenly the earthworm
represents a gigantic biological
advancement but then would that flatworm
next to a bacteria
suddenly it contains multitudes it is a
universe that flatworm is a Marvel an
almost unbelievable Testament to the
power of evolution
[Music]
I've never really thought about how hard
it would be to eat if I had to poop out
of my mouth at the same time but yeah I
guess I have a newfound appreciation for
the fact that our bodies are equipped
with an easy exit strategy for Waste but
you know who I wish would poop a little
less the subject of our next video
because now I can't help but look around
my house and wonder how much of it is
covered in their poop
[Music]
foreign
questions we get asked on Journey to the
microcosmos is how James our master of
microscopes stays safe while Gathering
and studying samples after all as
beautiful as the microcosmos is there
are plenty of parasites and pathogens in
there that we'd prefer to keep under the
microscope and out of our bodies
but while James has simple and effective
guidelines to protect his health like
making sure he always washes his hands
before and after handling samples and
never venturing into a pond with an open
wound there are times when those
measures don't quite cut it these are
the times when no matter how much you
protect yourself outside or inside the
micro Cosmos gets the best of you
these are the times of the dust mite
now we don't usually start these videos
with a warning but we're gonna do that
today while working on this video at
least four members of The Journey to the
microcosmos team found themselves having
a bit of a crisis about how clean their
homes were if you found yourself
sneezing and wheezing and running around
miserable with a runny nose because of
dust this arachnid is probably the
culprit though perhaps not in the way
you would expect
dust mites are small in the grand scheme
of things but large in the microcosmos
hitting just around 300 micrometers in
length their bodies are decked out with
four pairs of legs ending in feet that
act like suction cups as they wander in
their quest for three things water food
and darkness
dust mites love humidity because their
lives depend on it they don't drink
water so much as they osmosis it into
them relying on a salt-filled gland near
their mouth to absorb water vapor from
the air around them so if their
surroundings become more arid an adult
dust mite will wither away until it
eventually dies this is a challenge for
dust mites that live in places with
Seasons where wet and rainy Falls give
way to dry Winters to survive those
shifts they rely on the resilience of
their younger Brethren the nymphs whose
forms are able to withstand that lack of
moisture the seasons of the dust mites
life was one of the important clues that
helped scientists in the 20th century
understand their role in dust allergies
scientists identify dust as the source
of some kind of allergen in the 1920s
but they were not sure what it was
exactly about dust that did it they just
knew that people all over the Globe
suffered from dust allergies and that
these allergies were often seasonal
peaking in the Autumn particularly after
warm humid Summers and other possible
sources like animal dander or mold just
didn't quite fit right with the
seasonality of the allergy but in the
late 1960s scientists in the Netherlands
and Japan realized that the dust mite
might be the culprit they're found in
large numbers in the dust that lines the
unwashed and untouched corners of our
homes their populations peaking in time
with the runny noses and bleary eyes of
dust allergies but while experiments
confirmed that mites really were the
source of people's sensitivities to
house dust it wasn't clear what made
them so special
so we'll get to that in a bit James
often finds dust mites in the humidity
Chambers he uses to keep his microbes
alive these Chambers are made up of a
dish lined with wet toilet paper which
is just about all a dust mite needs to
feel right at home especially when
there's potentially some delicious
microbes to munch on so to keep those
other microbes from becoming a might
meal James has to regularly clean out
and disinfect the humidity chamber now
that cleaning might get rid of the dust
mites in the humidity chamber but the
problem is that our houses are full of
food for them because our houses are
full of us of flakes from our skin that
shed and gather all around and sustain
the invisible night and this is a
problem not just because it means the
might can thrive in our homes it's a
problem because food means poop
over the course of its life a Mite will
produce about a thousand pieces of poop
that are roughly the size of a grain of
pollen inside those bits of fecal matter
are enzymes that help the dust mite eat
its own poop and get nutrients that it
might not have gotten the first time
around but should the dust mite choose
to not revisit its prior meals the feces
will float around the room attached to
other particles until eventually they
settle down perhaps on a pillow or On A
Pet's bed or a car seat it's like we're
living in a gigantic snow globe except
that the snow is dust mite feces
in 1981 researchers confirmed the bad
news about this animal's poop people are
allergic to it to be more specific they
confirmed that dust mite poop contains
specific proteins that many people are
allergic to so if you're airing out some
sheets and you start sneezing what you
might actually be reacting to is dust
mite feces flying around the air now we
apologize for this image but it is
reality and it has embedded in our heads
so we have to share it with you as well
but we can offer what might be a small
Comfort there is another allergen from
dust mites that has nothing to do with
poop dust mites have a fairly lengthy
mating process sometimes taking up to
two days to finish this is a pretty
lengthy time for any organism but
especially for an animal that's only got
about a hundred total days to live over
the course of their life the female dust
mite will lay up to 80 eggs which hatch
into larvae that then go through several
different stages of development before
becoming adults with each passing stage
the dust mite sheds its exoskeleton
leaving behind its Youth and that
exoskeleton provides some other
allergens for people to react to but
though that is something people are
sometimes allergic to it really is
mostly just the poop that sets off
people's allergies so I guess there
really wasn't that much comfort there
after all
[Music]
for a trained and cautious
microbiologist dust mites can become an
unwelcome surprise once James brought
home some samples taken from a water
dish that his neighbor left outside for
their cat the surface was covered in
tiny round things and James thought they
might be rotifers but when he looked at
the surface of the scum under the
microscope there were no Charming
rotifers to be found it was mites just
hundreds of them crawling around the
slide it was so unpleasant that James
immediately bleached the slide now he's
not sure if that sample is their reason
but for days after James kept sneezing
and having to deal with a runny nose all
of which pointed to a potential might
Invasion fortunately though our homes
are not a Utopia for dust mites what
they really need is dark which is why
they prefer to dig themselves deep into
carpets and other soft things that give
them space to burrow dust mites have a
harder time dealing with materials like
suede that are difficult to hide
themselves in and they usually avoid
hard surfaces that are exposed to light
so for James his weapons against the
might Invasion were clear a vacuum a
mattress cleaner and a strong UV light
bulb it is one of the more ignoble ends
to one of our organisms we don't like to
hurt them unless they're hurting us
but I am sure that there is a dust mite
somewhere in our homes right now
settling into a soft dark Abode of its
own with hardly a care in the world for
the battle that was waged to bring you
this video
[Music]
I don't know it's grosser the idea of
eating and pooping out of the same hole
or the fact that I'm constantly inhaling
dust mite poop so let's end on a happier
note a festival of feces if you will
unfolding in the diverse strategies used
by both single-celled and multicellular
organisms to get rid of their waste
good
food one of life's great Pleasures
whether you're an organism whose body
can create its own food or you make do
with the consumption of other organisms
food sustains and connects life both
large and small but we're not going to
talk about food today we're going to
talk about what happens after no great
meal comes without consequences even
photosynthetic microbes produce oxygen
they don't need a byproduct that is
quite useful to many other organisms
including us and for organisms that have
to digest their food to extract
nutrients well there's all sorts of
stuff left behind when the process is
done in the world of the micro Cosmos
there are not only many varied tiny
organisms there are also many varied
ways to produce even tinier poop
[Music]
if you're worried about being grossed
out by this video or you really want to
make sure you're not missing anything
just know that some of this pooping will
require you to pay very close attention
some of this will probably look similar
to macroscopic bowel movements and some
will seem less so so let's start with
the more poop-like poop that comes from
some of the multicellular members of the
microcosmos particularly the ones with
digestive systems complete with
specialized regions for digesting food
and releasing solid waste
our dragon-like friend the gastro trick
is doing the old scrunching poop
probably after having finished a nice
meal made up of bacteria or protozoa the
food that came in through its pharynx
was then sent through the intestine a
straight tube full of digestive cells
after the remains continued their way to
the end of the tube where lies the anus
a microscopic Gateway out of the gastro
trick and into the world
that's all well and good for the more
complex organisms but how does one poop
when one does not have a butthole
well for some single-celled organisms
one becomes the butthole
touches the case for amoebas their
formlessness allows them to easily shift
their shape around to take in food via
phagocytosis the amoeba here happens to
have found a nice meal made of a ciliate
which is now contained in a food vacuole
filling with digestive enzymes those
enzymes will eventually break the
ciliate down allowing the amoeba to
absorb nutrients into its cytoplasm
but then what happens with the remains
well as we see with this amoeba here it
gets released amoebas and other similar
organisms use a process called
exocytosis to send waste back to the
membrane where it is removed from their
body
[Music]
you can see this again here in this
mastic amoeba slowly gliding along the
microscope slide while a round bit seems
to come off up top it almost looks like
it's leaving behind a little piece of
itself which I mean
maybe it is
ciliates have a more refined approach to
pooping which is to say they have the
unicellular equivalent of an anus called
a cytoproct
ciliates gather food into an oral Groove
and then consume it in the digestive
vacuoles that travel through the cell
eventually when the vacuole makes its
way to the cytoproct the contents get
out
and there you have ciliate poop
the way organisms poop the way microbes
poop are even more varied and wonderful
than we've been able to show you here
but you might be wondering how you get
from something relatively simple like
this ciliate releasing a small bit of
waste to something more complex like
this tardigrade with its more
compartmentalized approach to defecation
well the answer of course is evolution
but it's an answer that leads to many
more unanswered questions even within
animals the evolution of the anus or in
some species the cloaca is not well
understood as discussed in a 2015 review
paper with these spectacular title
getting to the bottom of anal evolution
and while the anus itself is linked to
the evolution of a digestive system not
all metazoans have a designated anus the
Hydra gut has only one opening which
means that the organism's mouth has to
pull digestive double duty and open back
up to release the waste and how that
system fits in with the evolution of
digestion overall is unclear much like
the evolution of sex anuses are a trait
that appears and disappears in
evolutionary lineages reflecting the
fact that they might be useful for some
animals and less so for others The
Duality of the hydra's mouth seems to be
working out great for them after all but
having a digestive system with a
distinct entrance and exit is pretty
handy too
for one it's just a little less
disgusting but it also keeps food
flowing in One Direction and that means
animals like the tardigrade and us don't
have to wait to finish digesting to eat
more food that would be annoying we just
get to keep eating all thanks to that
evolutionary mystery that is the anus
in the end though anus or not Everybody
Poops food after all might be one of
life's great Pleasures but all good
things must come to an end and perhaps
with the microcosmos we can find some
pleasure in that as well
and that is the conclusion of our
journey through the hind end of the
microcosmos it was beautiful it was
gross and I hope most of all that unlike
the nutrients these organisms were
getting rid of this video was not a
waste so thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us before we go
we'd like to also say thank you to each
and every one of our patrons some of
their names are on the screen right now
and these are the people that make this
Channel and videos like this possible
and for that we are so grateful if you'd
like to become one of them you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro and if
you'd like to see more from our master
of microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you'd like to see more from us there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
thank you
[Music]